Show comparables.
If you’re trying to raise money off an idea
that other people have done before
or you’re trying to buy into a current system
show comparables so it makes the decisions
easier for an investor to say yes.
One of the hardest things for the investors
to say yes to
is risk, right.
If you are the first person to try to do something
there’s a lot of risk attached to it
and so there might be a lot of opportunity
but then there’s a lot of risk.
And so it’s hard for them to say yes.
But if you can show them
that this has been done before
and the kind of numbers that it generates
then it’s easier for them to say yes
because they have a clear understanding
of the opportunity
and they know what risk level is.
So reduce the risk by showing comparables.
I got a great question from one of my
YouTube viewers
(love you guys!)
JawwCracker
and JawwCracker is trying to raise money.
He wants to start a kiosk in a mall around
the Tommie Copper product.
I’ve never hear of Tommie Copper but that’s cool.
So to get this thing going
you want to raise this money
you want to create this business plan
show me some comparables.
Show me who else has done a Tommie Copper kiosk
how much money they’re making
how much their cost are
and how their location is relevant to mine.
That’s what investors are going to look at.
It’s going to be a pretty simple calculation.
Okay, that other kiosk;
how much is it making
how much are they spending
and how does the mall that they’re in
compare to the mall that you want to go to?
If those numbers work out
it’s easy to say yes.
If they don’t work out
then it’s going to be a lot harder
to raise the money.
This might even be something
that the banks would look at
depending on how
your relationship is with your bank manager.
If I was financing this
it depends on the investor you’re going after.
This is not a venture capital type of investment.
This is more an angel investor
but not even a strategic angel investor.
It’s just somebody to give you money.
And this could be in the form of a loan.
If you want something to be in like
the 10-15% interest rate.
They give you the money
and you create your location
and go from there.
If you can get a strategic angel investor to come in
and put some experience
to help you grow this thing to multiple locations
that’s a bonus.
But I think you’re looking at just a guy with money.
You’re looking at, like a dentist
a doctor, a lawyer
who wants a hands-off investment
where they can get a premium return on a loan
that they’re giving you.
It’s probably your best bet.
And for them to say yes
show them comparables of people
who’ve done it before.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you liked the video
give it a thumbs-up below.
Let me know what you think.
Leave a comment.
You have a question
put it in the comment section below.
And if you liked this video
and you want to see more
you can subscribe to the channel
and see what else I’m up to.
Thank you so much
and I’ll see you soon.